ANANTONIO GUTERRES, secrétaire
gégénéral des Nations unies
- - Il n'y aura pas de véritabls
sosolutions aux problèmes globas
dede sécurité alimentaire
sasans réintégrer la production
agagricole de l'Ukraine
aiainsi que la production
alalimentaire et d'engrais
dede la Russie de la Biélorussie
dadans les marchés mondiaux,
etet cela, en dépit de la guerr.
LaLa guerre en Ukraine pourrait
prprovoquer une crise alimentaie
sasans précédent.
L'L'Ukraine et la Russie sont
dedeux des principaux producteus
momondiaux de blé, de maïs,
dede colza et de tournesol.
SoSommes-nous à l'aube d'une cre
alalimentaire mondiale?
J'J'en discute avec Nicolas Mes,
agagronome et journaliste
spspécialisé dans les enjeux
agagroalimentaires.
BoBonsoir, M. Mesly.
- - Bonsoir.
- - On ne s'en rend pas compte,
MaMais on parle d'une zone, qui
esest avec la Russie, un des
prprincipaux greniers de la
plplanète.
NINICOLAS MESLY
- - L'étranger, c'est parmi les
memeilleures terres de la planè.
PoPour l'anecdote, j'étais la en
UkUkraine avant l'invasion de la
CrCrimée, en 2015.
UnUn des producteurs de grains,l
didisait que pour poutine, c'étt
dede former un cartel de grains.
UnUn grand pourcentage des
exexportations de grains, dont s
dedeux pays contrôlent. Juste ds
l'l'huile de tournesol, pensez-,
7575 % de lui de tournesol qui t
exexporté vient de l'Ukraine. Et
l'l'Europe fait ses frite là-
dededans.
- - C'est gigantesque.
EsEst-ce qu'il y a encore de la
prproduction agricole en Ukraine
mamalgré la guerre?
- - Je suis en contact avec un
jojournaliste, un tiers à peu ps
dede la production... l'Ukraine
s's'attend produire moins de 50
mimillions de tonnes.
LeLes chants sont minés.
CeCe n'est plus Deschambeault
prproduire des denrées, c'est ds
chchamps de bataille.
VoVous voyez, je ne sais pas si
vovous avez les cartes avec les
poports, le but de poutine... on
paparle de Marioupol à Odessa. e
quque cherche à faire poutine,
c'c'est d'étouffer l'économie
ukukrainienne. Pourquoi? Parce e
c'c'est une grosse partie du PI.
IlIls essaient vers l'Europe de
trtrouver des chemins de fer,
cocomment acheminer cela. Mais ,
j'j'avais les chiffres...
6565 % du blé de la Turquie viet
dede l'Ukraine.
- - C'est pourquoi Monsieur
ThThérèse levée la main et disat
atattention. Ce n'est pas la
prpremière fois, parce que le pe
enen ont parlé récemment. Il
didisait qu'on s'en ligne vers e
crcrise, une famille en réalité.
CeCe sont des victimes
cocollatérales de ce conflit.
PaParlons aussi de la Russie. La
RuRussie est un grand producteu,
mamais ce qu'elle peut exporter
seses récoltes avec les sanctios
écéconomiques qui lui sont
imimposées?
- - On n'est pas indépendant dea
RuRussie. Près de la moitié des
enengrais qu'on utilise dans les
dudu Canada, on appelle des
enengrais azotés, c'est l'élémet
esessentiel pour faire pousser s
plplantes. Près de la moitié de
seses engrais viennent par bateu
etet proviennent de la Russie.
ExExactement. Le gouvernement
cacanadien a répliqué et a mis s
sasanctions, dont l'interdiction
auau bateau russe de Samarie das
leles eaux canadiennes. Ils ont
auaussi à partir de début mars
ininstaurer un tarif de 35 % sur
leles engrais provenant de ce
papays. La Biélorussie aussi.
LeLes producteurs agricoles de
l'l'est du Canada, leur coût de
prproduction vont augmenter.
OnOn me disait que pour le mome,
onon avait réussi à, si vous
vovoulez, avoir 75 % des engrais
didisponibles pour le début de a
sasaison, mais à partir de
jujuillet-apût, tout ce qu'il va
cocontinuer après, c'est les cos
ququi vont augmenter.
- - Les coûts vont augmenter de
bebeaucoup. Ça finit par se
répercuter dans la chaîne
d'd'approvisionnement, jusqu'au
coconsommateur nécessairement.
QuQuand on parle du grenier de
l'l'Europe, mais le Canada auss,
leles États-Unis aussi, ce sont
dedes grands producteurs de blét
dede grains. Est-ce que ça peut
cocompenser pour la demande
momondiale?
- - Ça pourrait compenser, je vs
exexplique pourquoi. C'est-à-die
quque le Canada produit la
CaCadillac des blé. Notre blé st
sosouvent à des mélanges pour ls
boboulangers dans d'autres pays.
OnOn le mélange avec d'autre blé
dede moins bonne qualité. Quandn
reregarde ça, on regarde le Cana
ququi produit la Cadillac des
blblés, on voit les États-Unis
prproduise la Ford de blé.
QuQuelque part, avec ce qui se
papasse dadans le monde aujourd,
lele Canada, je vous le rappell,
c'c'est le deuxième plus grand
papays du monde. On a les terre,
onon a l'eau, on devrait commenr
avavoir une véritable stratégie
alalimentaire. Vous montrez en e
momoment à l'écran des paniers
d'd'aide. Les Américains font ce
ququ'on appelle, de la "soft
didiplomaty". Ce serait le temps
dede jouer un rôle plus importat
popour nous.
- - Merci beaucoup!
- - Merci à vou